good morning thanks for joining us was
it a good night for the NFL in the move
by Ed Hochuli well I think they have to
do it now dan there's no question about
it I mean after the cam newton thing
where he laid on the ground I don't know
four six eight seconds face buried in
the turf and didn't miss a play um I
think that the NFL has to show that it's
vigilant whether it's for show whether
it isn't they did the right thing last
night when hockey we took them off the
field you should have called but the
fact that it was Ed Hochuli doing it and
not the person whose job it is to spot
it or their trainer that's what I found
interest well but you know what would
have happened it's very possible that
the spotter up sphere thing and it's
possible that the independent
neurologist on the sidelines in
conjunction with the spotter upstairs
would have done the same thing I mean
they're supposed to be basically three
safeguards here somebody watching
oftentimes with binoculars from upstairs
someone watching from the sidelines and
also the referee the officials on the
field is our Jenny brent is wrote this
week at the mmqb there also ought to be
the ability of the team physicians on
the sideline have the exact same ability
to to be able to take players off the
field and to be able to call medical
timeout the game last night tell you
more about the jets of the bills man I
you know was really bad and I know that
bills are missing Marcell Dareus and all
that but you know when is the last time
if ever that a Rex Ryan defense gave up
over 35 points almost 500 yards and made
Ryan Fitzpatrick look like Tom Brady it
just you know the bills is just not
working you know and at some point I
have no idea what's going to happen I
don't know what what the pergolas are
thinking right now but
if it continues this way I don't know
how he comes back for a third year yeah
I'm with you on that as well that I
think he started the season on on the
hot seat well we're talking to Peter
King from the mmqb com he's on a train
right now where are you headed by the
way I'm headed up to Boston I got a
doctor's appointment up there for the
day oh you go say it maybe you could go
get some luck catching time with Tom
Brady if gizelle will let you get in the
back yard there you never can tell what
might happen dance yeah the reaction the
reaction to Josh Norman not covering
Antonio Brown from around the league and
certainly the Giants who don't even play
Washington until the following week but
what did you make of all of this and why
didn't Washington eventually just say to
josh norman you know what go on Antonio
Brown and we'll deal with everybody else
because their game plan during the
course of the week was to be side
specific you know 22 not match up Josh
Norman with brown uh play after play I
think though after after Brown had some
early success I thought it was a huge
mistake to not make that change if if
Josh Norman's your best guy is very
clearly he is of course he should have
been on Antonio Brown and they should
play a match up when it's that you know
when it's sort of that when bechard
Breeland is getting killed by him you
got to make changes that's what coaches
good coaches do during a game they make
adjustments and they and Washington did
when does Mike Zoomer name is
quarterback uh I don't know that he's
going to but I'm sure that he's going to
start Sam Bradford you know there'd be
no reason any starting Sean hell if you
think that Sam Bradford has got enough
knowledge about the offense surely with
Scott Turner and Norv Turner being with
him now for two-plus weeks I think he's
going to have enough knowledge to start
this weekend against Green Bay I know we
love to overreact with the NFL but
Carson Wentz now the savior in phila
Sofia after beating the Cleveland Browns
are you on the bandwagon very much so I
mean the first series of his NFL career
the first time he's ever had a home game
college football pro outside of the
state of North Dakota he goes right down
the field throws a perfect fade to
Jordan Matthews in the end zone looks
like he's been playing for eight years
and I think what what everybody always
said about Carson Wentz is the
proverbial nothing fazes him him and he
has not seemed that all intimidated by
anything including WIP yeah he's just so
totally a is just so totally cool with
everything especially being in such an
intense market is Philadelphia and WIP
is the sports talk radio show they're
stationed there in Philadelphia and no
yeah they they tended they tend to have
come opinion not not afraid to skew
negative on WI ye in likeness on what is
happening with Vegas the stadium and the
Raiders that that possibility well Dan
you know you knew that the politicians
and the businessmen would get behind
this in Las Vegas and they would put the
funding down for it and they're on the
way to doing that with what they
approved this week and I think the one
thing to look at right now is that you
know the NFL led by guys like robert
kraft and jerry jones and dan snyder and
a lot of the newer owners even though
you don't think of those guys newer
owners hey I mean they're the more
aggressive owners they are fine with the
NFL going to Vegas I mean life has
changed in the last generation and I
think it was someone in northern
california sur as a Hail Mary I think
it's it's I don't want to say yet it's
likely that they'll go there but if you
ask my gut feeling Vegas is going to get
the Raiders I'll leave you with this
with dak Prescott with Carson wins
with Trevor Simeon they've had some
success now with Jared golf maybe the
backup to Case Keenum how long does that
backup role last and how much pressure
is on Jeff Fisher to get him in as his
starting quarterback well I talked to
Fisher in training camp about this whole
thing and he said very clearly I'm not
going to play Jared Goff until he's
ready no matter how much pressure dip
Fisher is going to be under and he's
going to be under tremendous pressure I
think he's probably going to stick to
his done on that now who knows if they
have a couple more 28 nothing losses you
never know but my whole feeling all
along has been that they're going to
treat Jared Goff the way the Bengals
treated Carson Palmer is right here they
basically said we don't care he's not
going to play and they set it right away
and Fisher says we're not going to play
this guy until he's ready until it's
time and I think that's smart it's easy
to throw him to the wolves right away
with a bad team but it doesn't make any
sense for the long term and I think even
though he has not been overly impressive
in the games or in camp is it makes a
lot worse if you put him in before he
was ready I'm right there with you I
keep saying hey this is a long career
and you know he's not a bust after one
week you know let's wait a little while
safe travels to Boston Pete good to talk
to you again thank you all the best and
thank you Peter King the mmqb calm the
Dan Patrick show weekday
on audience